[Music]
foreign
for the Press preview it's our first
look at tomorrow's front pages we're
going to check out the headlines tonight
with the senior associate editor at the
new Statesman Rachel cunliff and Anita
Boateng who's a former conservative
special advisor they're going to be with
us from now until just before midnight
very good evening to both of you we'll
chat after we've had a look at some of
those front pages for Saturday on the
front of the times is the headline chaos
Reigns in France it's the king and queen
consorts trip is postponed because of
those protests over pension reforms
while the telegraph says the UK's reset
with the EU is in disarrays his
Majesty's visit is stopped for now
Royal tour axed over safety fears is the
headline in the Daily Express
while the postponed State visit also
makes the front of the Daily Mail
the guardian carries a warning from
school leaders who say the brutal ofsted
regime is driving them to quit
the German chancellor has expressed
confidence in Deutsche Bank after the
company's shares fell sharply that's on
the front of tomorrow's ft
while The Mirror Has the story of a man
who went to Ukraine for dental treatment
after being unable to get an appointment
with an NHS dentist
and finally The Daily Star is claiming
that half-baked baguettes could be
blamed for a global stink crisis
and we're joined tonight by Rachel
kumliff and Anita boteng uh good to see
you both let's start with the front page
of the times shall we Anita actually
this is my favorite headline of all the
uh the stories about France chaos Reigns
in France
yes and the photo on the front page of
the times is quite extraordinary so I
would
um and so yes this is a story about the
protesting that is taking place in Paris
and have done so for quite some time
um as a result of macquan's decision his
Flagship policy to effectively raise
state pension age in France from 62 to
64. as a reminder for British viewers
um in the UK it's about 66 so I think
we'd be delighted to be at 64.
um and so as a result you've got um
you've got binman protesting you've got
lots of protests on the streets and it's
been so disruptive following macron's
decision to effectively use his his
powers rather than the powers of
parliament to pass the legislation
um many feel that he's acting like he's
almost like a king which is quite ironic
because this event has meant that the
king
um in the UK who was scheduled to visit
France is no longer going to be coming
so quite a dramatic series of scenes and
no signs of the protest to go into a
bait just yet no it's the same theme on
the front of the telegraph where actual
UK reset with EU in uh disarray the
workers are revolting in France and the
monarchy suffers
um and the sad thing about it is that it
was all meant to be a sort of
Celebration wasn't it of anglo-french
relations after what has been quite a
stressful few years
it was yes now I'm not sure to what
extent I buy the telegraph's framing of
this because that headline makes it look
a little bit like uh it's it's the UK
that's in disarray here or the UK that's
going to suffer as a result of this uh
this planned State visit not being able
to go ahead and you're absolutely right
that it was meant to be a celebration it
was the first state visit that kick
Charles was going to make to another
country and it was going to be a real
symbolic
um ceremonial example of how the UK and
and France were back on good terms after
a couple of years where we had some
prime ministers he said some not very
nice things about them and it is
disappointing that that's not going to
happen however if it's embarrassing for
anyone in this scenario it very much is
France macron wanted the visit to go
ahead and to Performance as a as a
country to say yeah we don't think that
we can host the British king because we
can't come
um we can't be certain you can't be
certain that there wouldn't be security
concerns uh that he would be safe
because of political situation our
Rising situation is so explosive at the
moment that we just can't make those
kinds of
of commitments that really doesn't
reflect well on macaw who very much sees
himself as a Statesman on on the global
stage I mean you've got the footage
there we've had some we've had quite a
lot of protests in the UK ourselves and
in recent months we've had quite a lot
of strikes and then you look at the
footage in France and go yeah they
really know what they're doing over
there they make our protests look pretty
pathetic don't they oh yeah and I've
been out there to cover the protest from
time to time and they certainly are
extremely organized they don't know what
they're doing and when we talk about the
issues involved Anita and Rachel touched
on it there macron really hasn't
necessarily communicated very well his
reasoning behind raising the retirement
age for from 62 to 64 and when you look
at other European countries here in the
UK obviously 66 Germany and Italy 67
Spain 65. why is he so determined do you
think to push on with this
well his argument and this is something
that has sort of bedeviled French
presidents for
a really longer
um because raising the state pension age
is one of the big political battles in
France because there is this concern
that effectively
um the the pension system will bankrupt
the country and that is macaron's Broad
argument and he sees himself as being a
kind of great reformer and this is very
much a kind of Flagship
um a policy that's going to in his mind
move France onto a kind of sustainable
footing and bring it more in line with
the rest of um the Western World when it
comes to the retirement age but I think
the way that he's gone about this in
particular and the fact that he's
effectively you know he lost him his
majority
um with his party in Parliament and as a
result of that couldn't get this
legislation through and then decided to
use his Constitutional Powers to make
this happen and I think that there are
many who see Matt Corners being someone
somewhat of a um you know a a kingly
figure in how he does politics and it's
very much about him even though I mean
it strictly is a presidential system and
so I think some of the ways in which a
protest has been reignited because the
protests were sort of dying down
um in Paris over this issue has
definitely been inflamed Once More by
the way he's gone about this you know
not seeking that parliamentary agreement
but instead deciding to use his powers
nevertheless as Rachel says completely
that this is an embarrassment
um for France and particularly an
embarrassment for Mac horn partly
because I think the not just because of
the concerns about the king's safety
were he two have visited but also I
think the Optics of him sort of I
presume sipping champagne in Versailles
um whilst uh rioters were on the streets
wouldn't have been perhaps the best
message from France yeah would you agree
with that Rachel
definitely uh the the Optics do not look
good it's a it's been referred to as a
potential Marie Antoinette moment
basically going let them eat cake while
uh rubbish is piling up in the streets
and people are rioting over the pension
age and uh he's up in Versailles having
a state banquet with the King of England
I can see why it's not a particularly
good look there was another
embarrassment for him when he was caught
on camera taking off a very very
expensive watch so that he wouldn't have
it on when he was on TV although
obviously that that clip was was
released so this idea that he is not a
man of the people that he is elitist uh
that he is very arrogant because he's
Anita says he is bypassed parliament in
this way even if what he's trying to do
is Safeguard France against the the
impact of an aging population which is
something that all Western countries are
grappling with at the moment it's a very
sensible reform but the way he has gone
about it in a country that has a real
history for industrial action and and
for lively protest has had a quite
severe consequences for him politically
and also for this much heralded State
visit it's very odd that footage wasn't
it whereas sort of hand disappeared
under the table and then when it came
back he wasn't wearing his his watch
very weird okay let's move on then um
also on the front of the telegraph uh
and in fact she's on a number of the
front pages uh Gwyneth Paltrow uh she is
currently giving evidence in trial over
this ski Collision that happened in 2016
at a very Posh Utah ski resort so Anita
what do you think of her evidence so far
I think that that she has a habit of
pulling one particular pose where she
slightly tilts her head to the side and
thins her lips and exact is exactly what
I do when I hear someone say something
that I'm really tired of
um and I think you can tell throughout
this entire thing that she doesn't want
to be there she doesn't think it's
necessary it seems like the amount the
sums you know she's counseling for one
dollar he's doing a half of three
hundred thousand dollars the sums are
relatively trivial and therefore this
seems like quite a lot of a circus
um over a small amount of money
um and I think she's made the point that
she feels if she weren't famous that
this wouldn't have gotten to this stage
um I must say I don't know how I feel
about the fact that America routinely
televises all its trials like this
because I honestly couldn't imagine
anything worse but she seems to be I
don't know bearing up her gay
uh yeah that uh that evidence uh ongoing
um Rachel
um and she does look uh pretty tired and
pretty Fed Up about the whole uh episode
because it has been going on for a long
time now a number of years
yeah it's been going on for years over
what as Anita just said a relatively
small amounts of money and you know on
the one hand it's almost certainly the
case that he wouldn't be suing her were
she not famous or I mean you don't see
someone for 300 000 unless you think
that they have three hundred thousand
dollars uh but we have also had quite a
few revelations in in the last couple of
years of celebrities who perhaps don't
always behave in the most appropriate
way and think that their Celebrity
Status will protect them from ordinary
consequences she just got artists before
we came on air
um by by the opposition lawyer
um whether she inquired whether he was
okay after the skiing crash and she had
this line that was sort of when you when
you've been in a crash psychologically
you don't always feel in a space to
inquire after the person who caused the
crash which just feels like it it could
have been a line from a TV series that
this viewer said or something like that
but I I agree with Anita when she when
she does that look which you saw her on
screen dick a second ago they're sort of
head to one side that really really uh I
I I I I do find that quite convincing
she's she's got the look nailed down but
then she is an award-winning actress
yeah and apparently her her children are
going to give evidence next week as well
um and let's finish on this uh very sad
story and the ramifications of it the
head teacher who uh took her own life
because of the ofsted report that was
going to downgrade her school uh Anita
well what do you think of the way
schools are judged does it work does it
need to be changed
um well I know my sister is a teacher
and I think that the way that ofsted can
strike fear into the hearts of teachers
I think is is under appreciated and the
stress that it puts um teachers and
pupils under
um you know is no mean feat I think that
it's an imperfect regime and I think
it's probably the best we have in the
face of Alternatives but I definitely
think there is no harm in in ofsted
reassuring itself and obviously all of
the teaching community that it's doing
everything it can to provide an
environment in which like they are
genuinely assessing but also
um you know allowing schools to flourish
and allowing teachers to continue to to
feel like they can teach and teach well
yeah it's the sort of the unknown aspect
Rachel isn't it that's I think so
stressing so stressful for for teachers
you know that phone goes and and you
know the inspectors will be there any
minute
and it really does seem to cause a huge
amount of additional stress and panic
and work in a sector that is already
very much overworked part of me wonders
whether the real problem here isn't
offset because I think even teachers and
head teachers in schools would agree
that it's very important that schools
are regulated and and are checked up on
and that that's really important for
students and and parents and indeed for
teachers the real problem I think is
that what is going on in our schools is
that we have a massive teacher shortage
we know that teacher pay is a huge issue
they've been on strike this month and
increasingly teachers and schools are
being asked to pick up more and more
what we'd normally call I guess social
services that have been cut back on our
community services dealing with kids who
have mental health issues or have real
problems at home or who are living in in
poverty and all of the other community
services that you would expect to deal
with those issues have been so radically
scaled back or not working or demand is
too high that it falls on teachers in
addition to sort of their teaching load
so I think there is real anger in the
teaching community that often inspectors
who just come in for a couple of days
don't understand the conditions that
they are working under and just how much
their their workload has increased and
their roles have expanded there was real
anger over ofsted not making allowances
when they went and did inspections sort
of during lockdown or straight after it
in the pandemic just what schools were
having to cope with and I think until we
kind of realized that we're asking
teachers to do a much greater expanded
role than many of them ever realize when
they signed up for the purpose of you
know teaching that anger is is still
going to be there and it's a really
really tragic case we shouldn't read too
much into the exact circumstances of
that one woman's death but we can have a
conversation about what it is that we're
asking teachers to do and whether or not
it's sustainable